deu was the first user to awaken one for
all's potential to use the quirks of all
its former users initially toa's Quirk
only copied the appearance and voice of
the people she transformed into but once
her Quirk awakened she was also able to
copy those people's quirks the villain
getton has a quirk that allows him to
manipulate all ice around him but when
his Quirk awakened it allowed him to
freeze old the water around him in order
to create a lot more ice shigaraki Quirk
allows him to Decay anything he touches
but when it reawakens it allows him to
spread the Decay to other objects and
people making it possible for him to
destroy a third of a city in seconds
Dobby is known for his powerful blue
flame Quirk but in the final Arc he
awakens the ice side of his Quirk
allowing him to use both Fire and Ice
finally ultos Quirk initially allows her
to make something she touches float in
zero gravity but when it awakens that
floating spreads to others allowing her
to make hundreds of people float at once
for more mha content subscribe to anime
uproar right now